and valiance dr. pepper is making his  first approach into the launch area  hello Americans look upon a true  American Hero this man or egg is a  pioneer named dr. pepper whence he was  enrolled into the government program he  is as reestablished in 1885 as the 23rd  doctor due to the success of amount of  regeneration  he started to mutate and lose a few  limbs now in position for clearing of  Kristofferson's case but I think we  should all agree ladies and gentlemen  this is one of the most courageous  objects of poetry over here what the  crap hey I'll get those rocket he  inspires all in young Possible's  there's a wonderful work with spine  shock absorbers a labyrinth of glue we  hope the best for his gently world  soldier aha there is no room for failure